meaning everybody thank you for your
patience we have the first result of
friendship for the Deming constituency
declaration result of whole community
election of a member of parliament for
the DeLeon constituency I Colin
Everett's being the acting returning
officer at the birth election to hereby
give notice that the number of votes
recorded for each candidate at the set
election is as follows an authority on
doing and that's young and then it's all
yet enough Hanson Davis George Welsh
Labour to zero five seven three twenty
thousand five hundred and seventy three
votes driving pink thank you rip earth
Thomas Phillip Welsh Liberal Democrats
one zero three one 1031 vote even Gene
Robinson Paul John Clyde Kumari the
party of Wales one four eight one
1481 votes
right Matthew Gerard Welsh Conservative
Party candidates
okay supplying me glad I'm coming one
six three three three sixteen thousand
three hundred and thirty three votes in
quick change the number of ballot papers
rejected was as follows one to the
unofficial mark zero voting for more
than one candidate nineteen that's what
I do universities in writing all marked
by which the voter could be identified
to education and being marked or wholly
548 in total 69 and I do hereby declare
that state is George Hansen has been
duly elected to serve as the Member of
Parliament for the dowing constituency
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]